sabías que puedes medir el tiempo sin
tener un reloj el día de hoy aprenderás
cómo hacerlo al igual que él y lo hizo
cuando uno de sus pasatiempos favoritos
se salió de control y comenzó a tener
problemas con su mamá por no terminar la
tarea a tiempo
lily ama hacer pulseras y collares solo
que le gustaba tanto que olvidaba a ver
el reloj y no se daba cuenta del tiempo
que había pasado de qué manera podía
darse cuenta de que ya había pasado
mucho tiempo y que era hora de hacer la
tarea estando en casa
lily comenzó a observar que sus pulseras
y collares no eran del mismo tamaño ya
que cada uno necesitaba diferente tiempo
para su elaboración
así que lily comenzó a contar las
pulseras y los collares que le daba
tiempo de hacer hasta las 6 de la tarde
que llegaba a su mamá
el lunes hizo siete pulseras y llego a
su mamá
el martes hizo tres collares y llegó su
mamá el miércoles hizo tres pulseras y
un collar pero cuando llegó a su mamá
todavía no había terminado el jueves
hizo dos pulseras y un collar y cómo
terminó antes de que llegara su mamá
hizo la tarea el viernes hizo un collar
y una pulsera terminó la tarea y hasta
le dio tiempo de jugar con sus juguetes
antes de que llegara su mamá
con esta información lily se dio cuenta
de que al hacer un collar grande se
tardaba lo mismo que al hacer dos
pulseras así que para organizarse mejor
y hacer la tarea antes de que regresara
su mamá decidió comenzar a medir su
tiempo con el número de collares y
pulseras que hacía en este caso lilia
aprendió a medir su tiempo sin emplear
los minutos o horas como lo hacemos
comúnmente en la antigüedad no existían
relojes cronómetros ni celulares que
pudieran informar a la gente de la hora
en la que podían encontrar abierta o
cerrada una tienda no se podía
determinar con exactitud una hora para
dormir y en algunos lugares las personas
sabían que era el comienzo de un nuevo
día porque escuchaban el canto de un
gallo al amanecer y para ellas era
tiempo de despertar
hoy ya contamos con muchas cosas para
poder medir el tiempo aunque al igual
que el il y tú también puedes crear tus
propias medidas por ejemplo puedes medir
cuánto tiempo tarda en llegar a la
escuela cuando en ir al parque y cuanto
a la casa de un amigo para medirlo
puedes contar el número de pasos largos
o cortos que das y al igual que el lille
y puedes experimentar con ellos y
divertirte